ainsi à dunkerque et dans la communauté
de communes des hauts de flandre ce qui
représente environ 250000 habitants à
compter de vendredi soir et jusqu'au
lundi matin un confinement sera
désormais adapter le week-end donc dès
ce week end les déplacements resteront
possibles pour certains motifs tels que
des achats de première nécessité ou
encore des motifs médicaux vous
connaissez ces motifs et les commerces
autre que les commerces alimentaires
seront fermés les centres commerciaux
d'une surface supérieure à 5000 mètres
carrés il y en a 10 dans ces deux aires
urbaines ne fonctionneront plus qu'en
clic et emporté les jauges de
fréquentation des autres commerces
seront réévaluées à 15 mètres carrés par
client les protocoles sanitaires seront
rétablies sur les marchés l'obligation
de port du masque sera renforcée dans
les agglomérations c'est à dire partout
où la limitation de circulation est à 50
kilomètres heures ou moins par ailleurs
dans l'ensemble du département cette
fois la vente d'alcool à emporter ainsi
que la consommation d'alcool sur la voie
publique sont interdites